[Musique]
si on commence pas à s'ouvrir on va
mourir j'ai vu des changements une
chaîne travaille pas dans la même école
oui c'est important de voir des modèles
simples c'est ici qu'on forme depuis
plus de soixante ans d interprètes d
auteur et aussi des metteurs en scène en
théâtre en français et en anglais
certains diplômés sont devenus de
véritables vedettes au québec et à
l'international
on change rarement une recette qui
marche et pourtant une petite révolution
se joue à l'intérieur des murs de
l'école nationale de théâtre pour
recruter davantage d'étudiants issus de
la diversité
ça commence et l'élargissement de la
définition quand on parle de diversité
diversité culturelle oui mais aussi de
région de langue
socio-économique aussi alors on a pris
des efforts dans les dernières années de
s'ouvrir vers le monde
et pour s'ouvrir les colas tisser des
liens avec des jeunes en créant des
festivals de théâtre et en offrant des
stages de courte durée le but se faire
connaître auprès de milieux
historiquement moins proche du théâtre
et la façon de recruter le talent a
aussi été révisée on a simplement invité
du monde issus d'autres horizons de
faire partie du panel décisionnel pour
le concours d'entrée à l'école ce qui
veut dire je dis souvent c'est comme
changer de paires de lunettes des fois
ci n'ont pas tous les mêmes lunettes on
peut juste voir une chose quelqu'un
n'est pas un manque de passion qui a
fait hésiter au ntumba s'inscrit à
l'école de théâtre mais plutôt une
inquiétude légué par son père c'est
quelque chose qu'il avait trouvé très
difficile de lui un acteur noir au
québec qui il voulait pas je pense que
je puisse traverser les mêmes motifs un
culte qu'est ce que peut il aller en
psycho avait rien qui me donnait cette
passion que gilles pour le théâtre fait
que j'ai fait mes auditions et ça a
marché c'est la phrase qui nous laisse
savoir que le frère andré c'est comme un
méchant monsieur comment ça se passe ça
se passe super bien moi j'avais beaucoup
d'appréhension quand j'ai fait justement
les outils aussi à d'autres écoles mais
l'école nationale de théâtre c'était je
pense l'école qui me parlait le plus
surtout quand on parle de diversité
quand on parle de du corps professoral
qui est vraiment très
hétérogène j'ai mon stage avec une
professeur qui elle aussi était convoité
moi qui aime me parlait justement de
l'attrait qu'elle avait eus à cette
école ici c'est ce que mon personnage
les efforts déployés par la direction en
écoles ont des répercussions que l'on
peut même chiffrée et jeu côté du
programme atteint du côté anglophone je
dirais toujours à 50 à 60% des étudiants
qui sont issus de la diversité dans
chacun des cohortes cette année du côté
francophone je pense que c'est même
rendu à 45 ans pour ça parce que elle
connaît mais en plus de repenser le
processus de recrutement on passe sous
la loupe le contenu des couilles cette
année on a un cours de dramaturgie
africaine postcoloniale
cd dramaturgique ont étudié pas
littéralement je dire on était vraiment
dans un discours au centre est avec
avec les classiques qu'on connaît tous
au pire menace et s'est dite tout en
déchirant parce que travaillant racines
c'est essentiel pour un élève puis on
dit pas on va plus faire racines on dit
qu'est ce qu'on va mettre maintenant
côté de racine la dynamique du groupe
est ce que ça change
oui forcément ça change puis ça change
si
si la classe est réellement
représentative - justement j'ai
l'obligation si j'ai deux mètres sur le
parcours de ces jeunes l'aide des
professeurs en qui peuvent se
reconnaître
aussi c'est important des textes dans
lesquels ils peuvent aussi se
reconnaître des enjeux qui les
concernent
mais mais que l'école se transforme la
question se pose est-ce que le marché du
travail lui change au même rythme c'est
incroyable ce qu'on voit maintenant dans
le milieu anglophone sait si c'est
impossible d'avoir assez de talent qui
sortent des écoles alors je pense que ça
s'en vient rapidement pour le milieu
francophone
ce
qui doit changer ou de la de juste
maître du monde qui sont de la diversité
devant l'écran et personnes qui sont à
derrière l'écran c'est aussi ça doit
changer l'eau ici que le chemin sera
encore long avant de faire sa place mais
le défi ne lui fait pas je prête une
pionnière non plus parce que je sais
qu'il y en a eu d'autres avant moi mais
de pouvoir être un symbole je pense pour
d'autres personnes qui pensent que c'est
pas possible qu'ils se voient jamais